les français l'adorent c'est un des
acteurs les plus populaires dans le
métier et pourtant il envisage de
raccrocher
il en ressort à 82 ans il affirme qu'il
ne tournera plus au cinéma ne montera
plus sur les planches sauf parce qu'il y
à un sauf la suite avec christophe
duchiron et frédéric bazille ce matin
dans le salon de son domicile parisien
ils nous regardent l'oeil rigolard et la
moustache amusé il est 10h45
c'est l'heure de la mise au point la fin
du flou artistique
j'abandonne aussi de massot si le grand
coup de foudre le grand défi revient
jean rochefort n'est donc pas encore en
retraite de la république des arts
cinématographiques en un peu plus d'un
demi siècle de carrière il a tourné près
de 150 films seulement ces dernières
années sauf exception il avait la
fâcheuse impression tourner en rond je
reçois depuis quelques temps et même
depuis deux trois ans pépé part on va
comment le retour de pépé
comment se débarrasser des livrets
quelques ambitions artistiques qui ont
d'érosion certaine mais je trouve
qu'avec l'âge maintenant on a envie
d'exister un peu et de dire vous savez
l'adolescent que j'étais ressemble à
celui ci
en 1978 il reçoit le césar du meilleur
acteur pour son rôle dans le crabe
tambour de pierre schoendoerffer
trente cinq ans plus tard il a juste
quelques rides supplémentaires et le
respect de tous les publics
j'ai peur que des enfants en bas âge par
exemple confondez histoire d'amour avec
un film de terreur en voyant en gros
plan qu'est-ce caslava de gages
elle a mon âge ce qui est déjà pas mal
jean rochefort est un menteur
sympathique et un homme d'une élégante
drôle à l'âge du capitaine rochefort n'a
donc aucune importance c'est un enfant
elles le sont j'ajouterais même que
c'est pour tout public
effectivement je n'y avais pas pensé
le 13 mars prochain il est à l'affiché
d'un film espagnol l'artiste et son
modèle il en est fier